how are you guys holding up in the in
isolation together
I mean being being pregnant and so close
together pregnant I mean like less than
two weeks apart I know I ain't crazy I
will say this being next-door neighbor's
first really cuz it's gonna be a good
thing or a bad thing it's been the best
thing yeah because we have each other
and I feel like going to each other's
homes masses fell like you know there's
a change of scenery and so it's really
helped having each other and leaning on
each other's stay like common positive
during this time yeah I mean well it's
it's not like you guys haven't been
close we've seen you like fans of yours
have seen you over the last five seasons
and before that being so close but are
you appreciating in this particular
moment even more how close your
relationship is yeah because the good
thing is is we don't want to divorce
each other as sisters
uh-huh and we can and we can I think you
know sometimes I think a lot of people
are struggling right now with people
they're stuck in their household with
and I guess what has made me appreciate
our relationship anymore is like we
truly love being around each other and
we do there so it isn't like I'm like oh
just need to go away from her if
anything it's made me really appreciate
our relationship and our bond and know
that like breehn I really can survive
together through thick and thin through
our ups and downs and I feel etic a lot
of people are realizing that through
quarantine whether it's loved one family
members you to realize like do we make a
good team or not
and I'm fortunate enough to know like
yeah this is the girl if the world was
to end and I got a you know pick that
person she's right here I know we could
survive together and have fun and fight
zombies if you know that happens XO and
it almost feels like that is what would
happen next isn't it are you crazy
nobody I'd be shot I won't be shocked
yeah now we watching
Nikki go through this Howry how was she
handling her
pregnancy from your point of view she's
actually she's handling it really good
there's times where I'm like just so you
know this is gonna rock your world you
might you know taking this a little too
easy but it's a good thing but she she's
in a really really well the only thing I
have to keep reminding her is that yes
your body changes and it is hard but I'm
you just have to know like you're
creating the miracle life because the
vanity part has been a little hard on
her well and it's not like I think I'm
Giselle but it's like this worked hard
to just be t in shape and I'm a body
type that it doesn't come easy it's you
know to be where I've always been it
took a lot of hard work and when you see
years of that hard work no matter what
you do everyday or what you consume your
body is just changing it's difficult to
accept at times and then I think of my
baby and I get really happy but she does
have to get me through the science cuz
it's like whoa my hips are moving in a
different direction and my thighs have
doubled and my belly button is popping
out and you just you go through all
these changes and I think a lot of women
relate to that especially your first
time around you try not take it to you
well you know being in the position that
you guys are in and being so in touch
with your fans as mothers and soon-to-be
mothers you know I'm sure a lot of
people are reaching out to you and sort
of giving you advice or saying what to
do and what not to do how much weight do
you put to those sorts of suggestions
that people give you from the outside
world you know it's I especially think
being first time and getting a lot of it
just like you probably did when you were
pregnant at birdie and I feel like Bree
and I sometimes have a different
perspective on life or how we believe
you live life like even though I can be
super bougie like at the end of the day
I truly do love mother nature and like a
simple way of life and want my kid to be
raised a certain way a lot a lot like
what she's done with birdie so when
people are giving me advice I'll come to
because I look at birdie and I birdie is
a little kid who has an imagination and
doesn't care about grabbing a phone and
looking at technology she wants to make
robots out of boxes and be outside and
playing so I'm like hey okay I like what
you've done so I use people wrong should
I do this now
we'll still disagree a little bit on the
way like labor works and different
things like that I want to do something
maybe a little different and she doesn't
fully believe in that way but I trust my
doctor and so yeah and I think to like
the one thing I've realized is it's
great to get all the advice but you
don't have to pick and choose to feel
what's right for your life and your body
- right but hearing it firsthand from
other mothers to go through it is better
than googling cascoon scary stat so any
time like the first time birdy got a
fever I instantly text my cousin cuz she
has three kids and she's like you don't
need to go to hospital so I was like
okay because Google is making me feel
like I have a dying child so I think
it's great to hear that you know
firsthand from people compared to just
like googling it's nice - it wouldn't
work for them yeah it's late yes yes you
need elicits you know what I mean yeah
how big of a chapter is gonna be in the
memoir that you guys are writing so you
know Bree and I we worked on her memoir
for two and a half years and literally
when we were done writing it I actually
I wasn't even through my big public
breakup like that actually happened yet
so I remember we were thinking right in
the second one it was gonna be about my
wedding and the next chapter in my life
and you know - you know Bree moving on a
jerk not moving on after birdie so we
got to go in and change a few things
but other than that were already talking
about our next book cuz Arnhem isn't in
this book
there's a little bit about my breakup in
the book not much we're really good in
deep on like our child's which my what
the journey that got us to where we're
at does he day yeah and for my sister
and I we even though we've been on
reality television 7 everything you felt
like you know everything about us the
one thing we've never really opened up
about is our childhood in the way we're
raised a lot of the downs we went
through and the one thing with dad is
like you know what we don't have to keep
that part private because for us we
thought if we would talk about it make
us instant victims and we don't like to
victimize ourselves but we looked at
like rapture survivors and if other
people have been in our situation
instead of going down one path maybe
they can take the path that we took
where you put your head up high like you
know what I'll make it better and so and
you actually start to see it in the
season of total bail is this season
there's a couple episodes where we have
to go to our family and say hey we're
gonna start talking about some childhood
stories is it ok which was super
uncomfortable we lost so much sleep it's
tough because until you know we see so
many people come out with memoirs and
you don't see the backstory of things
with trauma that really happens to make
that book whoa we have the cameras roll
on that and it got yeah those are tough
decisions to make to to be able to you
know talk to your family about the
things that you want to reveal in that
book how much did you guys talk about
whether or not we should include certain
parts of our upbringing in this I mean
there's definitely parts do you think
like ok I do have to protect my family
in some ways but yet overall we just
told her family like if we're gonna
write a book we're going to talk about
our journey we don't want to hide a lot
like we don't want it to be so watered
down like we can protect what we want
people to know it and these are gonna be
stories that no one's ever known about
the Bella Twins so we just want your
permission that like hey this is the way
we were raised and this is way we grew
up in this what made us the women we are
today like it wasn't all
peaches and cream it wasn't easy like we
had to go through a lot a lot of hard
times but those hard times made us
really strong badass women yeah so and
my poor mom and dad were just like you
know they got pregnant with us at 18 so
who's raising kids and that's tough to
do I decided to have a child at 33 years
old I could have never imagined in my
20s having a child I was never ready for
that
so I just we it was hard but they signed
off so yeah yeah you know having gone
through the experience of writing your
memoir and prepping to write another one
that must have given you a lot of
perspective on where you're at now in
terms of being a parent and you know
soon to be a parent when you think about
your children and what you want for them
if they wanted what you've achieved if
they want to kind of follow in your
footsteps what would you say to them wow
that's a great question you know I think
for myself the biggest thing I would say
to birdy is just to never have the fear
of hiding you really feel you are like I
was a young girl I always wanted to
please everyone and I always had a fear
of like expressing myself as if I'd get
in trouble for it and I don't want her
to ever feel that I feel like at a young
age if you can start expressing who you
are and have the courage to say this is
actually my opinion I'm not gonna go
along with everyone else and to truly
find the bravery and courage just to
stand for what you believe in
it's gonna make you a successful strong
woman whatever success is to you if it's
just wanting to go save the trees and
you have a big voice to like go up
against companies on that or it being a
CEO whatever it is I want birdie to just
know like it took me a long time to find
my voice I want her to find at a young
age cuz that's gonna make her what I am
now what took me a long time to achieve
right and for me I mean what Bree said
is so spot-on but also
to not regret your decisions or even
mistakes to learn from them I sometimes
wish the stuff that I know did now I
wish I could have applied that when I
was younger as far as like you know
sometimes I feel like when were younger
we make these mistakes or certain
decisions would feel like it's the end
of the world like life is over but I
wish I had the tools to grow from them
then like why did I why did I do that or
why did I want to make this decision I
wish I knew about journaling when I was
younger and meditating and I just for my
child I want to give them all the tools
I can so that they can even start to
grow when they make decisions in Middle
School in high school and know that they
can just become better people then and
not wait to go through it later in their
20s or early 30s yeah I think those are
all things that no fans of yours are
also getting from you they've been
getting that stuff from you for a really
long time too one thing that they're
going to really enjoy is your induction
into the W Hall of Fame where does that
rank on your list like that's at the top
top five
yeah and it up three yeah I say top
three for sure you know the thing about
when you're inducted into a family when
we got the phone call from Vince McMahon
and to hear his explanation why he
believed we should be inducted it
literally brought tears to our eyes and
just it made us feel like everything you
worked hard for all your blood sweat and
tears all the times that you just were
like should I give up because everyone
makes me feel like I should give up and
you just kept going and just the long 13
years of just the grind it just made
everything feel like wow like it was all
worth it and that it was all for this
one thing and it was it's a very surreal
feeling when you're not ever knew what
it would feel like and to be honest we
were shocked we got asked this early on
we thought okay maybe five 10 years from
now we'll be inducted but I never
expected the emotions and the feeling
and so it just it's nice when you're are
work is recognized yeah because I you
know at the end of the day like no
matter what we do whether we work at a
desk or a teacher we're in the hospitals
at the front line
or an entertainment we want some at some
point 70 do I know sometimes that would
be my struggles when I have certain
bosses or when I work with certain
people because I just created a little
recognition of the hard work I was
giving and the Hall of Fame is like the
ultimate recognition that you can have
and it makes any barrier you have broken
or tried to break and what you put into
that you're just like it makes it worth
it it's this gonna be a weird analogy
but I almost it's like when the women
wanted to vote and they fought so hard
and they got that you came that time
we're like now women can vote and I
couldn't even imagine that feeling like
I get chills when I think of it I was
like oh my goodness that's almost what
the Hall of Fame when mints called and
said so too it was like whew he's really
recognized like what BRE and I wanted to
do here for 13 years the Harvard cuz you
never know if those people see it or not
and so it's an incredible feeling